je commence cette vidéo par lafarge en
préservant le montage et je me rends
compte que directement lorsque c'est
commencer ma vidéo sur mon plan ce matin
ici eh bien j'ai tout simplement l'audio
voyez c'est pas de dios si vous regardez
sont la thaïlande
j'ai pas de diot donc j'ai mon auto qui
a pas marché donc comme no 2 n'a pas
marché ben on va quand même l'utiliser
on va se faire du doublage
ici c'est hollywood alors lâché en train
de s'installer tranquillement tac je
prends le téléphone tout va bien je
crois que le som marche alors
aujourd'hui je vous parlais de l'as
nouvelle monde de samsung la galaxy aux
actifs de que j'ai au poignet qui est là
regardez comme elle est belle elle
scintille de tous les côtés de milf le
jeu c'est pas du tout vous raconte donc
j'en profite complètement je tape dessus
regardez elle a un joli bracelet bomba
mais mais mais si on en parle ailleurs
mais si on a la new york bonne idée
allez on y va on parle du rebond
je suis vraiment très très fort en
doublage
[Musique]
regardez-moi ça change d'hôtel avec vue
sur l'hudson river le soleil se couche
aux meilleurs jeunes arrivés choisi ni
énorme journée il est 23h30 et minuit en
france
et j'adore ses débuts de sunrise heures
c'est beau en face le new jersey et là
c'est un vrai régal
et alors regardez ici on va voir ici
regardez cette pieuvre d'hôtel elle est
complètement incroyable je crois que
c'est la première fois qu'on veut le
coût d'un rockeur hausse tigres ont en
fait ce n'était pas une chance si vous
ne suit pas ce que signifie tout
simplement énorme qu il vraiment
vraiment cool regarder ça avec le petit
con quand on arrive à revenir se poser
faire ce qu'on veut c'est vraiment cool
le petit rangement en chef daniel il ya
tout ce que vous voulez ici et puis en
scène de pêche au courage d'un dernier
mois ce truc la douche était énorme
on peut y rentrer et je sais pas combien
attendons c'est pas le but que l'on peut
et surtout par l'état de la baignoire
regardez ce truc de ouf et pour une fois
us j'ai eu baignoire qui sont très grand
prix pro font la loi qui suivent ce
grand amoureux de baume je vous raconte
pas l'histoire
j'avais vraiment un taxi cliff bordé
c'est tout simplement
revenez ici pour parler de google vont
pas du pixel 4 qui va être présenté
demain pour l'instant je vais vous
parler d'autre chose je voulais près de
massmart watch qui se dévoile à moitié
la galaxie où à chaque type de que
j'utilise depuis quelques jours et que
je trouve vraiment tout simplement
énorme
quand je vis de montre aussi le pire ou
plutôt cool
la galaxie médiatique deux ont déjà
parlé quelques jours j'ai fait le hand
boxing voulait montrer très rapidement
et c'est une honte je trouve vraiment
vraiment vraiment cool parce qu'en fait
elles pallient un peu les erreurs qu'on
a faites avec les primes agressive
objectif qui était pas complètement
terrible et là on progresse hop c'est de
madame plus de lumière il fallait faire
nous ici j'ai pas d'éclairage de studio
donc que l'éclairage est pas
complètement optimale el bali un petit
peu à tous ses problèmes de se dire
effectivement ben voila j'ai une montre
j'ai pas qu'à prendre j'adorais des
caves en sont à galaxy watch sur la
grecque si vous êtes actif j'en ai
trouvé ça moins bien les finitions était
cool mais le premier faisait pas rêver
avec la galaxie ou autres s'activent the
truck en tout cas samsung allie à
corriger ces points à proposer propose
en tout cas une montre qui est vachement
intéressante qui est moderne qui est
actuel avec un beau design avec beaucoup
de possibilités de personnalisation et
ça c'est vachement bien mais surtout ce
qui est très intéressant c'est l'os
tyson
c'est l'expérience et la qualité des
finitions et pour ça c'est vraiment
irréprochable
le premier tôt que j'ai vraiment aimé
déjà que cette montre c'est sur celle là
c'est la finition acier j'adore la
finition si ça trouve vraiment hyper
hyper hyper qualitatif très joli j'ai le
bracelet cuir qui donne vraiment look
hyper hyper élégant très urbain très
classe très caujolle alors pas forcément
hyper sport il faudrait changer le
bracelet mettre un bracelet en silicone
pour les bénis avec parce que comme ça
ça me fait un petit peu peur par contre
je trouve vraiment élégante et c'est
vraiment tous les retours qui m'ont été
fait une banque qui élégant qui est
vraiment cool l'ol j'adore aussi très
facile très pratique très bien pensée
tyson alors bon je sais pas si vous
aimez tyson moi j'aime bien ouverts aux
as jamais tyson pour moi dans les aurès
qui ressort vous avez effectivement
tyson yahoo air eau s de google ayant
effectivement l'ouest de apple qui
marche parfaitement bien que vous avez
choix entre plusieurs possibilités
plusieurs petites et de personnalisation
soit le contour en acier inoxydable soit
le contour en aluminium léger soit
effectivement les bracelets en cuivre à
pouvoir de bracelets en silicone
différentes couleurs différentes
personnalisation en fonction de vos
goûts vous avez la possibilité de la
voir en 44 mm comme je lis ici ou en 40
mm en version 4g en version bluetooth et
pour vous donner une idée de prix du
prix ni nos principes a tout appris par
coeur vous en douterez la version axes y
est la version acier inoxydable on est à
3 199 euros elle est quand même assez
élevé le tarif est pas cadeau cadeaux
mais par contre le produit vraiment bien
et la version aluminium léger on à 299
pour vous montrer un petit peu combo de
ce qu'on peut faire j'ai pris deux
exemples la version 4g
+ 44 mm puissant d'acier on va arriver à
469 euros
c'est assez élevé si on veut la version
bluetooth 40 mm en aluminium 299 envoyée
il ya un vrai monde en fonction de ce
qu'on veut définition qu'on veut pour
son plaisir avec cette montre en tout
cas comme ça moi je la trouve vraiment
vraiment vraiment magnifique dites moi
ce que vous en pensez vous qu'on
commentaires comment vous la trouvez moi
comme ça je la trouve tout simplement
ypres à ypres hypra canon vraiment très
très belle les finitions sont sublimes
bas c'est un prix qui est extrêmement
bien réussi deux de la part de samsung
on a donc une onde qui y fera connecter
il prat qualitative et bien évidemment
du bluetooth 5.0 du wifi du nfc pour le
paiement dématérialisé pour passer votre
pass navigo ce que vous voulez du gps en
train de faire tout ce que vous voulez
avec l'ol je vous dis c'est tyson celle
au s2 samsung
personnellement je vais bien je trouve
pratique je trouve assez bon
personnalisable vous avez beaucoup de
possibilités vous avez un éventail qui
est très complet que vous montre un
petit peu comment ça marche j'ai
plusieurs possibilités vous balayez vers
le bas vous avez accès à peu à vos
réglages un peu standard en ce qu'on
peut retrouver sur sur toutes les
montres là vous verrez quand même plutôt
pas mal donc ça c'est c'est vraiment
intéressant
lamballe hier ce côté vous êtes toutes
vos notifications météo messages e-mails
les compagnies de l'autre côté la gym
ont suivi d'activité je vais avoir mes
applications favoris se retrouvent ici
je vais avoir à mon sport effectivement
si je veux les faire un peu de sport et
bien j'ai toutes mes infos ici ma
fréquence du rythme cardiaque
lorsqu'elle a été prise à la dernière
fois la météo à manhattan il fait 20
degrés c'est chaud ici encore ça c'est
assez cool les rendez vous d'aujourd'hui
je peux rajouter des widgets of mac les
petits widgets que je veux ensuite vous
avez deux boutons un bouton ici là le
bouton ok permet de revenir en arrière
et boutons du bas qui vous amène
directement dans vos applications et
c'est là que ça devient intéressant et
c'est là que la magie opère vous avez
plusieurs possibilités pour venir
naviguer
soit vous naviguez comme ça et que votre
doigt vous choisissez ce que vous voulez
ouvrir tac je reviens en arrière
ce que vous pouvez ouvrir et puis vous
choisissez un vous passez d'un à l'autre
comme ça soit vous avez un petit système
comme ce qu'on avait un peu sur la la
galaxie watch que je trouve vraiment
génial ne vous avais pas en fait le
cadran monkey arena tournée mais vous le
faites avec votre doigt comme ça en fait
vous venez de passer sur le côté et là
vous naviguez directement et sajoo c'est
vraiment génial en plus il ya un retour
haptique donc on sent vraiment la
vibration sous le doigt moi
personnellement je suis très content je
trouve ça vraiment vraiment bien pour
moi ça vient effectivement bien et bien
éviter d'avoir cette montre avec cette
grosse bague qui venait tournée qui
était très très très masculine on a un
design qui est beaucoup plus fort
beaucoup plus léger mais on garde la
fonctionnalité par défaut n'est pas
activé c'est à vous de venir à l'activé
directement dans vos paramètres mais moi
je trouve ça vraiment génial c'est un
vrai régal
dans ma musique c'est pour mieux
naviguer à droite à gauche allez vous
voulez je trouve ça vraiment vraiment
couleurs après vous pouvez le faire avec
le doigt un petit peu classique mon pote
faire comme ça c'est dans les paramètres
ce qui est cool c'est que c'est
extrêmement intuitif c'est pas intrusif
au milieu de l'écran le retour haptique
est vraiment vraiment cali donc ça c'est
vraiment cool à soir que vous avez un
écran amoled vous savez à l'écran 360
par 360 pixels soit une 1,2 pouce pour
le modèle en 40 mm soit 1,4 pouce pour
modèle en 44 mm mais évidemment l'écran
16 millions de couleurs ça vous vous en
douterez à l'intérieur d'un processeur
de 1,15 gigahertz dual-core 0,75
gigaoctets de ram et 4 gigas de mémoire
dont 1,4 disponibles pensait pas vous
avez 4 gigas disponible c'est pas vrai
vous avez l'eau est ce vous avez donc un
gain de 4 gigas de disponible on a bien
évidemment un accéléromètre un gyroscope
un baromètre un capteur de luminosité un
capteur du rythme cardiaque
un micro qui est caché ici un haut
parleur de l'autre côté elle est
certifié ip 68 certifie résistante à
l'eau et à la poussière jusqu'à sa ktm
vous pouvez donc l'emmener jusqu'à 59
ça ne s'est pas borné à 50000 se et vous
pouvez nager dans la piscine
ici dans une baignoire dans une
baignoire déjeuner absolument pas mais
c'est pas très grave pouvait prendre des
douches avec ça c'est bien alors moi
j'avais toujours en dessous je crains
toujours là effectivement avec ce
typologie de bracelet en cuir
moi je vous recommande d'aller prendre
vos bavaud douche mais pas avec des
bracelets en cuir avec des bracelets en
silicone et là par contre c'est vraiment
vous avez en plus à l'intérieur une
batterie de 247 millions père heures
pour la version 40 mm et pour la version
44 mm vous avez une batterie de 340 me
lit en paire eur alors l'autonomie
pour moi c'est un truc qui était
vraiment hyper intéressant cette montre
parce que samsung vous donne une
autonomie durée de batterie en tout cas
de 43 heures soit deux jours pense que
là dessus vous serez d'accord avec moi
sur le calcul moi par contre j'ai lu
beaucoup plus j'ai eu trois jours et
demi au bout de trois jours et demi
massé lorient 1 1 % elles s'éteignent
l'autonomie des pointes à plus de vos
usages de ce que vous allez en faire
de quelle manière est ce que vous allez
construire de quelle manière est ce que
vous allez l'utiliser moi je les utilise
pour avoir mes sms regarder quelques
e-mails la notification j'ai fait très
peu de sport avec ça
non mais moi aussi dans la salle débat
qu'on va changer de pièce qu'on retrouve
est pas là très peu de sport avec
beaucoup pour les modifications alors
j'imagine que si vous l'utilisez
davantage pour le sport si vous cherchez
effectivement un toujours la soliste et
que vous êtes beaucoup plus dessus et
bien effectivement les trois jours ni
vous les aurez pas vous serez sur deux
jours c'est ce que dans tout cas samsung
sur l' usage standard si maintenant vous
allez vers le saas qui est extrêmement
intensif je pense que vous arriverez sur
un jour un jour et demi
mais bon franchement pourrait tout le
temps dessus il faut vraiment vouloir
rien un truc que j'ai trouvé un peu
bizarre avec cette montre à un moment
donné c'est que lorsque je la prenais
pour aller faire de la trottinette et
bien le reconnaissait un exercice de
vélo à elle me disait allez vous faites
du vélo
on commence à calculer l'exercice bon ça
c'était un peu le souci
et lorsque des fois je si si je marchais
où je marchais vite et bien le
considèrent que les sports alors
effectivement marché c'est du sport mais
elle vous le met directement l'activité
physique alors ça ça peut avoir un sens
mais le coût de la trottinette pour le
vélo voilà l ai pas trop habitués et
tout ce qu'elles ont en tout cas c'est
que avec le gps vous êtes en déplacement
vous allez plus vite qu'à la normale qui
a priori ça se paraître assez logique
que vous soyez sur un vélo elle va
effectivement pas reconnaître les
mouvements des gens elle va reconnaître
je pense
la vitesse le positionnement donc c'est
pour ça qu'elle est assimilée
directement un vélo mais en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que pour l'exercice
physique je trouve ça bien alors
peut-être pas les applications natives
pour tout ce qui va être usage sportif
un petit peu poussé peut-être avoir des
applications plus spécifiques derrière
mais en tout cas telle qu'elle est là
telle qu'elle est livrée pouvez
l'utiliser pour avoir un suivi lorsque
vous faites du sport en amateur bien
évidemment pour pouvoir effectivement
pas en vous un nouveau niveau de votre
rythme cardiaque j'ai toujours la partie
de la gestion du stress pour venir un
peu souffler relax vous détendre donc
c'est cool moi je pense que l'ol c'est
intéressant taisen j'aime beaucoup c'est
pas parfait mais pas loin
c'est en tout cas un réseau est favori
au niveau des smashes moi cette montre
je l'adoré je trouve vraiment très
élégante dans cette version en tout cas
la version en acier avec le bracelet
cuir je trouve extrêmement élégante vous
pouvez la mettre en toutes occasions
pour aller partout vous soyez sur un
événement habillé d'un événement plutôt
standard normal je parle pas de faire du
naturisme quand je dis habillé habillé
pas bi et trans est vraiment plus
habillée costard snow qui brille ça
marche avec une banque comme ça c'est
vraiment élégant elle et passe partout
je la trouve vraiment cool vous changer
rapidement drass les vous partez à la
piscine nager ou faites votre sport
c'est vraiment hypra sympa autre point
qui est extrêmement positif à elle est
compatible ios et android et sa s'engage
absolument pas à la fête
voilà pour moi c'est une très jolie
monde c'est une très très bon
aussi moi ce que je trouve vraiment très
intéressant avec cette galaxie watch
actifs de que j'attendais pas là présent
nettement avant qu'ils l'annoncent
évidemment j'ai ri pas deviner qu'elle
allait arriver mais je pensais pas que
les sortir d'une deuxième on a déjà eu
la galaxie watch active
il n'y a pas longtemps qui était pas mal
mais à qui manquait pas mal de choses là
watch active devient vraiment corriger
le tir fait rentrer samsung une fois de
plus en avant dans ces eps smartwatch va
corriger un petit peu le côté design
trop masculin trop cheap et roja seuils
de la galaxie ou watch et nous apporte
une montre qui est superbe et tout
l'intérêt avec la personnalisation
derrière eh bien chacun va pouvoir se
lampard et en faire ce qu'il veut
s'apprêtait directement avec et puis
pourquoi pas avoir différents bras c'est
pour pouvoir changer
je pense plutôt un peu vite peut-être
plus féminin quoique quoique je pas des
conneries là dessus moi je trouve bien
le seul truc c'est qu'il ya
effectivement un petit peu cher je vous
dis hein les tarifs mal à savary on peut
monter quand même je suis presque 500
euros 469 euros pour la plus grosse
config approuvé pas obligé de mettre
autant d'argent à vous de voir ce que ce
qui vous va le mieux ce que vous
préférez n'est franchement comme ça pour
moi c'est celle la plus belle confie que
c'est comme ça qu'on est là qu'on en
tire le mieux en tout cas cette montre
et je la trouve vraiment très très très
belles heures et fastueuse peut aussi
changer les cadres en voulait s'appuyer
puis vous venez naviguer comme ça là
vous avez plusieurs cadres en au choix
comme il est naturellement comme ça je
trouve vraiment très très élégant
j'adore vraiment cool a vous de me dire
ce que vous en pensez de 7,5 son galaxy
welsh active 2 est ce que vous la trouve
intéressante je continue à garder au
poignet pendant quelques temps je laime
bien je l'adoptent je trouve vraiment
cool je trouve qu une fois de plus
samsung frappe fort au niveau de
l'écosystème au niveau du produit
samsung paye de sujets pas si vous
l'utilisez vous pouvez d'abord vous est
donc pas mal de possibilités avec cette
jolie monde pour faire plein de choses
c'est un vrai compagnon au quotidien
elle offre plein de solutions effet
d'abord à une version 4g c'est vachement
bien le fait pour avoir du wifi dessus
aussi
c'est vachement bien c'est un vrai petit
beau bijou voilà vous nous dire ce que
vous en pensez quant à nous on se
retrouve dès demain pour parler des
pixels 4
la ja vachement de choses à dire ça va
être aidant j'ai hâte je suis très
content de pouvoir être ici avec vos new
york puis regardez je profite un petit
peu du coucher de soleil sur l'hudson
river on va la nuit très clairement est
arrivé il est 7 heures du soir
regardez-moi ça regardez moi ça il ya
beaucoup de lumière ici on voit un peu
moins bien mais regardez la parole
j'adore ça c'est magnifique avis sur ce
je vous embrasse je vous dis à demain
des bisous chaos